[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dave roberts dodgers manager
won a world series as a player with the
red sox and as the dodgers manager and
former national league manager of the
year joining us from spring training
dave good to have you back on how did
the sort of uh abbreviated spring
training affect your approach on how
you're going to get everybody ready
you know uh dp it was uh it was
different it was a frenzy
uh there was a lot of trust that had to
be kind of uh accounted for because
we couldn't talk to the players and we
just had to hope that they were going to
be ready
um starting pitchers in particular and
so once we get there it's kind of an
overall conversation assessment and see
where guys are at but uh with our guys
to a man it's been really good and uh
you know whether it's clayton or uh
walker you know guys are putting their
work built up and uh
it's been good but obviously and we'll
get to freddie later but i know that you
know freddie uh just kind of getting him
his feet wet so he's kind of a late
arrival to camp but guys like that but
right now we're kind of on track
how are you told that the dodgers are
signing freddie freeman
so i i kind of joke uh dp that it was
kind of the worst kept secret in all of
baseball that and i say that in a sense
that it's something that i think
everyone wanted and
uh we we were involved in trying to make
it work and then uh you know once that
olson trade went down um i was with
andrew and we were going over our roster
and some other baseball ops guys
upstairs uh it's kind of about maybe 10
o'clock at night and so we finalized the
deal that night so andrew and i uh
called freddie together and
congratulated him and uh
i know he was thrilled and just to keep
getting him in that dodge uniform man
it's pretty special didn't he show up in
a suit holding his baseball glove
yes he did so the funny thing is that he
had a suit he had some like suede boots
or some shoes on so
this is the bobby cox uh pedigree man
it's like you know you're thai classy
and all dressed up so i think it was jt
and some other guys that came a lot of
grief and uh he was laughing he goes
okay i'm gonna fit in just fine here in
this ball send this out with this
organization i was wondering about
clayton kershaw when i saw the deal it
felt like it was a team friendly deal
and it was a one-year deal
and it feels like this might be year to
year with clayton or am i reading too
much into this
i i think that it's uh it's fair as far
as a year-to-year situation i think
right now he's uh in a position where
he can dictate where he wants to play
and obviously
he uh he's a dodger for life a dodger
legend um but texas is home
and so that's been kind of made public
but right now we're he's a dodger for
for this year we'll see what happens
next year um and and i think that
there's some uh incentives in there um
but uh obviously the player clayton uh
liked the deal and and there's something
to be said for being a dodger so you
could see him it's not out of the realm
of possibilities that he could end his
career as a texas ranger
you know what with clayton i i don't
want to speak for him dp but i could see
that that's a possibility but uh that's
up to him and alan so and i don't i
don't know that answer did you go to
football games this past year
i did i went to uh my first uh
uh rams game and uh so i saw that nfc uh
championship game and then i i actually
had a chance to go to the super bowl as
well so uh
pretty remarkable uh stadium and crazy
vibe it was awesome
well i know you're a football guy you've
talked about that before uh you know you
do you
look out there and go how could i
possibly think that i would want to play
that sport professionally
oh absolutely that was the best decision
i made to get off the great iron
and get on the baseball diamond i had a
chance to meet uh dominic and sue a
couple years ago at dodger stadium and i
just see this guy knowing that
he out he's got me by probably 150
pounds and he can outrun me so that's
what you're dealing with in the nfl man
it's crazy
are you up on all the rule changes
no you want to feel me no
i i have a cheat sheet that's helping me
a little bit and then i know there's a
shohei ohtani rule that's in there and
like that it seems to be a lot going on
how do you uh how do you keep all of
this sorted out
you know what i got a bench coach bob
garrett he's so he's the rules guy danny
and i have no idea man it seems like
they change all the time and there's
going to be something that's going to be
implemented here in about a week or
maybe april 6th uh the day before
opening day i don't know i just i got
enough on my plate to worry about these
uh until it's cemented i really don't
pay too much attention do you think that
we're going to see more players
try to do what shohei otani's doing
um
no
because i don't think that they can um i
think in theory i think every player
wishes they can be sho hey otani but uh
there's a reason why maybe ten years
from now though dave that you you you're
almost preparing for usually your best
player is a pitcher and a shortstop and
so i don't know if we would see
a 12 year old go i plan on pitching and
hitting you know and playing the field
in uh in the majors
yeah i mean i i guess that's fair i
guess that's fair because i think that
right now uh you look at a little bit of
a broader look um as far as travel ball
and where now i when i play there's no
such thing as a as a po and a po i guess
is a pitcher only
and so
you know when i came up when you came up
we kind of pitch play the best players
certainly going to pitch at some point
so uh certainly shohei uh is uh is a is
a mate he's a superstar as a face one of
the faces of major league baseball so
yeah people might try to emulate so yeah
if you look 10 years down the road
potentially
might give players some more runway to
do that which would be great um but man
that shohei is really special is dave
roberts dodgers manager joining us dan
patrick show you hit 23 home runs
is that right in your career
uh hey but you forgot the one postseason
homer so let's let's uh
for the sake of this discussion i had 24
major league homers okay all right so
you're inside the parker you you
averaged 2.4 home runs per year you
you're you had problems with your launch
angle didn't you dave
i i absolutely it was more negative
launch angle so that's just not good so
it just certainly affected my war i'm
sure and you had eight home runs in
2005. were you were you juicing back
then there were a lot of questions about
that
uh you know what i wasn't i just uh i
was ahead of uh the analytics thing in
the launch angle so um yeah so i think
my angle was maybe like 21 degrees that
year so yeah i clipped a few best
picture you hit a home run off of
kurt
schilling
and i bet you remember the at-bat
i'll bet you remember the at-bat
it was at uh the old bob
bank one ballpark okay and uh it was a
three run homer and uh he threw me a uh
he threw me a three one heater and uh it
was it was pretty cool yeah do you ever
bring up any of these things to
you know now that you're not playing
anymore but do you when you run into
somebody would like if you saw schilling
would he know
that
you knew that you took him deep
uh so schilling definitely knows we've
talked about it in the past i got
another good one for you
so i was in double a in jacksonville
playing for the jacksonville suns and
this was 1998. so john smoltz was on
rehab with the braves he comes down and
pitches for the uh the greenville brace
playing we are hosting and so first
inning i hit a homer of john smoltz so
that's the biggest one i've ever hit but
it wasn't a big league homer so
the funny thing is that after the game i
had uh john smolt signed the ball
i still have it to this day and i bring
it up to him uh maybe every other time i
see him and uh he's not too thrilled
about it yeah you normally don't get a
baseball sign to be like if you picked
off tom brady and you said tom would you
autograph this i can't imagine you
imagine if you homered off randy johnson
and you said hey randy would you be
willing to sign this you know the next
time you got up to the plate
i hear you but i've already so the thing
is that i bet that does happen with
brady
and i i need you to dig on that and the
other part of is that i didn't get the
chance to hit the homer off randy
because he drove me in the ribs anyway
so um
yeah so i got the the repercussion of
getting hit by ranch i guess i could
have had him sign that ball what did it
feel like
i still feel it um it was that it was 97
to seemer
and it was opening day maybe 2003 i
tried a bunt
um and then the ball went foul and one
pier always told me said hey man if you
try to burn off randy he's like the
nolan ryan guy where if you bunt you
better make it fair because if you don't
the next one's going to be in your ribs
and
i swear daddy it was like
he's up there with this big black glove
right under his eyes and you got that
visual and i think it was i swear it was
like the top gun radar lock right on my
ribs and i can just dance it and then it
was this heat-seeking 97 two seamer just
running right into my ribs so uh it like
i said man it it it hurt pretty uh
pretty bad but i stayed in the game why
is that okay in baseball
i think it's okay because randy's randy
nolan's nolan roger was roger and i
think pedro's face i think part of it is
like the fear of the baseball for the
pitcher is everything and so
guys are kind of uh very bonds up with
the big elbow guards and they got the
protection all over the place and you
know that's still gamesmanship i still
believe that you got to be able to
control uh pitching inside commanding it
but i think at times
you know to get hit once in a while it's
part of the game
the dodgers will win the world series if
we play a full season and there is
a postseason
wait we are winning the world series in
2022.
so i know where you're going with that
no what the world series this year put
it on record
you are winning the world series
we are winning the world series that's
our focus that's our goal um but to your
question
we are winning the world series
if
if
um
our starting staff
stays healthy
i know that's vague but i don't want to
and then
that's my answer okay but you're
you can dig in a little bit on that but
i i think it's about our starting
kitchen you know just keeping our guys
healthy okay where do you rank your
rotation in baseball
our rotation of baseball i i put us
i put us somewhere in the uh
i put it somewhere in the top ten okay
who has the best rotation in baseball
i would say um
and
i would say right now for me i think the
mets do
what makes the grom so special
um the velocity uh the command the glove
side command of his fastball
uh
his ability to pitch up in the zone
um
there's a there's a breaking ball in
there there's a changeup in there um
it's a it's a it's a great throw it's
just hard to pick up from what i hear
but i think that glove side command
coming in on left handers up and in
that quadrant up and away to the
right-hander it's just tough to tough to
barrel up
you see the best pitcher in the game
if you look at sheer kind of
numbers
i would say it's hard to debate
um but the body of work that our guy
walker bueller
should be in that conversation
so you're guaranteeing that you're going
to win the world series this year
i'm putting it on i'm putting it out
there putting it in the universe
well you should believe in your team i
mean if you said well you absolutely
should right
i mean it's nothing like here you know
we're placing a bet and you could lose a
limb if you don't win the world series
that's right that's right and i'm not
rooting against you or i you know i
would bet you just for content's sake on
the uh show but
i mean
i don't know
like we could bet wine but
you know i love your wine i don't have
any wine so you yeah i i need to i i
went to uh dinner with our buddy ted so
uh we got to get you some more some more
uh wine so ted's my guy he's your guy
and uh we need to do a little uh wine
deal so we gotta replenish uh your wine
stash
i am the uh jacob degrom of wine
drinking
yeah i love that just letting you know
just letting you know i could be kershaw
year to year because at my age i am you
know day to day but uh yeah i
by the way just so and dave won't bring
this up but i'm bringing it up his uh
his red stitch pinot
93 points from uh wine spectator it's
it's great did you give us
do you give your players your wine
so i've got some i've got a few cases
enroute so uh once we break here we get
to dodger stadium i'm gonna take care of
my guys so uh we got a lot of wine
drinkers which uh is just interesting
because when i came up there was all
about the beer and so we got a lot of
wine drinkers so i gotta i gotta share
some of my red stitch absolutely and you
couldn't do that with the old red sox
because they would drink that prior to
the game probably
so yeah yeah you're right hey but but
dan you've got to have something to call
them the nerves man so it wasn't wine in
2004 but uh whatever we drank it worked
right was it
whiskey it was whiskey yeah
do you remember the brand of whiskey
i i don't i don't um but i do know that
you know when it's like 37 degrees and
it's freezing and you're in fenway park
your back's against the wall
um
whatever everything's on the table hey
if i was facing mariana rivera i'd
probably drink too
oh absolutely kevin millar had it right
he was he was a man way ahead of his
time hey uh great to talk to you as
always and uh thanks for joining us all
right hopefully we'll talk soon
all right dp take care you're the best
that's dave roberts dodgers manager